is a key subject for a lot of great  thinkers in the DAO de Jing Lao Tzu  wrote knowing others is wisdom but  knowing the self is enlightenment ah  knowing yourself is he talking about  what I think he's talking about no  Eleanor once again none of these  philosophers is ever talking about  masturbation let's move on to this  week's main events David Humes a  treatise of human nature you read this  right I did well I tried to well I tried  to want to um actually could we postpone  this lesson I befriended John you from  next door and I thought I could learn  from him that's a great idea  Humes bundle theory of the self is  fairly close to Buddhism yeah no dürer  that's why I'm doing it do you hear  music that's not music  that's EDM  [Music]  [Applause]  what are you doing I don't know you were  right no more pretending it's time for  me to be myself  what's up boy Eleanor you broke John you  you